es gibt nicht weniger Abtreibung wenn
wir sie verbieten es gibt nur mehr Tote
also Menschen die an den Abtreibungen
sterben ich nehme bei einer Abtreibung
einem Kind endgültig ein für allemal
alle Zukunft wenn ich mich sowieso dazu
entscheide abzutreiben und an
grasgeschicht brauche und dann noch mit
dem Gefühl rausgehen außerdem ist doch
noch eine Mörderin hurra bei einer
Abtreibung ist immer am Ende einer tot
oder Vergewaltigung Krankheit ungewollt
schwanger alles kein Grund keine Frau
darf abtreiben wer abtreibt tötet sagt
Cornelia Kaminski my body my choice
erwidert dr me to sanial die Mutter von
zwei Kindern hat dreimal abgetrieben
ich glaube dass Frauen was besseres
verdient haben als eine Abtreibung weil
ich die Abtreibung für die schlechteste
Lösung halte im Schwangerschaftskonflikt
weil damit immer ein Menschenleben
beendet wird
[Musik]
ich will eindeutig sagen eine Abtreibung
ist nicht die Tötungen eines Menschen
ich würde sagen das ist noch kein Mensch
[Musik]
es geht um Frauenrechte es geht um
Selbstbestimmung es geht um Leben und
Tod bei mir auf der Couch
[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu hallo Cornelia
hallo Leon schön dass Ihr da seid ihr
begrüßt euch mit breitem Lächeln ja
warum denn nicht na ja die eine ist
komplett dafür die Abtreibung zu
verbieten die andere sagt nee habe ich
ein Recht drauf das sind ja sehr
unterschiedliche Positionen was
erwartest du denn heute von dem Gespräch
ich hoffe mir ein bisschen Verständnis
für meine Position und ich bin sehr
gespannt auf die Argumente und ihre
Position was zu erzählen hat
relativ ähnlich also ich möchte ja auch
überhaupt erst mal verstehen
weil weil ich halt auch so einer
komplett anderen Richtung komme und ganz
häufig haut man sich ja immer nur
Argumente um die Ohren und dann gehen
alle mit genau derselben Meinung nach
Hause ist sehr langweilig ich möchte
dass Menschen selber über ihren Körper
entscheiden können weil eine
Schwangerschaft eine Geburt es sind
einfach unglaublich also körperlich
aufwendige und unglaublich wirklich auch
erschreckende Abläufe also es ist
wirklich das schlimmste was in meinem
Leben gemacht habe war ein Kind auf die
Welt zu bringen es war auch das
wunderbarste aber es ist halt wenn ich
das gezwungen hätte machen müssen wäre
schrecklich gewesen Cornelia du nennst
Abtreibung vorgeburtliche Kind töte wie
tu hat abgetrieben ist sie eine Mörderin
für dich das ist nicht meine Aufgabe zu
entscheiden das war jetzt ein Mord ja
also im Mord würden wir sagen es ist
Vorsatz das ist hinterhältig das ist
jemand die man keine Chance gegeben hat
was wäre dein Wort wenn es nicht
Mörderin ist weil vorgeburtliche Kind
Verkürzung ein Kind zu töten was ist das
dann sie ist eine töterin das ist jemand
der ein Kind das bei ihr sein wollte
gesagt hat ich will dich aber nicht ist
das für dich okay nein du in einem Satz
Abtreibung ist für mich ich fände es gut
wenn wir ein Recht hätten dass Menschen
die Möglichkeit gibt Kinder zu bekommen
wenn sie die wollen was in diesem Land
auch nicht einfach ist die andere Sache
ist aber Menschen die diese Kinder nicht
bekommen wollen die sollten das Recht
haben selbstbestimmt darüber zu
entscheiden zwei völlig unterschiedliche
Position Cornelia will schon wieder
dagegen tut mir gefallen wir machen mal
Platz und gehen jetzt auf volle
Konfrontation bitte einmal aufstehen
[Musik]
jede soll mal raushauen können wo sie
steht ohne dass die andere ihr ins Wort
fällt und trotzdem die Chance bekommt
was dagegen zu halten wir haben gerade
schon gemerkt es gibt sehr
unterschiedliche Standpunkte und ich
will jetzt dass jede von euch einmal die
Zeit die Möglichkeit bekommt wirklich
klar zu argumentieren ich stehe hier bei
diesem Thema und gleichzeitig soll die
anderen in dem Fall dann zuerst du mir
nicht sagen du erwiderst gar nicht egal
was Cornelia sagt allerdings möchte ich
über deine Grimassen Gestik dir die
Chance geben ja so ein bisschen
zumindest anzudeuten wo stehst du wie
siehst du das Cornelia deine Meinung zu
was bedeutet Abtreibung für dich
für mich bedeutet Abtreibung das Ende
eines Lebens ich nehme damit ich beende
im Grunde genommen beende ich eine
Zukunft ich beende einen Potenzial ein
Geschenk das einer Frau gegeben wurde
und ich mache das im Grunde genommen
ohne zu wissen was tatsächlich später
mal passieren wird vielleicht ist genau
dieser Mensch der jetzt in mir
heranwächst derjenige der meine Probleme
löst die Tour steht hier komplett
eingefroren und da könnte man denken die
hat das Ding nicht verstanden aber ich
glaube sie hat komplett verstanden sie
reagiert nur nicht so emotional
Abtreibung ist verboten in Deutschland
da braucht man eigentlich gar nichts
ändern das steht im Strafgesetzbuch und
Paragraph 218 das sind Tötungsdelikt und
da gehört natürlich auch hin weil ich ja
bei einer Abtreibung ein Menschen töte
und das sollte meines Erachtens auch so
bleiben denn jede Straftat jede Handlung
die wir nicht gut finden die anderen wir
irgendwie mit Hilfe des
Strafgesetzbuches also egal ob das jetzt
Raubmord Totschlag Kindesmissbrauch oder
sonst was ist das wird im
Strafgesetzbuch geredet nehmen wir eine
Straftat eine junge Frau wird
vergewaltigt ungewollt schwanger
Beschreibung jetzt okay oder nicht bei
einer Vergewaltigung im Bus muss man
erst mal sagen ich das ist so furchtbar
ich habe jedes Verständnis für eine Frau
die dann hergeht und sagt nee das kann
ich nicht aber ich würde auch die Frage
stellen ist es richtig wir haben ja
keine tote Strafe in Deutschland
herzugehen und zu sagen aber das Kind
kriegt die Todesstrafe das kann ja nun
nichts dafür also als Cornelia eine
Abtreibung mit einer Todesstrafe
verglichen hat das hat mich jetzt
persönlich überhaupt nicht berührt also
das das ist tatsächlich ein eine
Metapher die ist dann so groß dass sie
jenseits dessen soll ich wirklich das
Gefühl habe nur das stimmt mich so gar
nicht mit überein noch mal in Einsatz
Abtreibung in dem Moment okay Abtreibung
ist nie okay aber immer man kann immer
mit Verständnis reagieren Abtreibung ist
nie okay mir tut du stehst weiter
Erstatter ja das ist das das die die
Meinung gibt es auf der Welt ja dass das
weiß ich das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie
ich bin jetzt nicht schockiert also
wirklich nicht tauschen jetzt die
Position
jemand sagt ich bin gegen Abtreibung
grundsätzlich was erwiderst du ich finde
es absolut in Ordnung wenn Menschen
nicht selber abtreiben wollen ich finde
es absolut in Ordnung dass sie diese
Position haben wenn sie andere Menschen
aktiv daran hindern wollen damit habe
ich Probleme wenn sie es anderen
Menschen die eine Abtreibung sich
wünschen die für sich notwendig finden
dabei beschweren dass das finde da darf
ich an Probleme zu haben jetzt gibt's
Leute die machen sich stark damit du
diese Möglichkeiten eben nicht bekommst
wir wissen es gibt nicht weniger
abträumungen werden wir sie verbieten es
gibt nur mehr Tote also Menschen die an
den Abtreibung sterben Cornelia rastet
auch nicht aus ich habe wirklich gedacht
die wird mit Armen und Beinen rumtretern
die schüttelt bestimmt den Kopf aber
immer noch mit einem Lächeln ich glaube
der ist auch ganz ganz wichtig wie sie
rüberkommt stellen wir uns vor
Konfrontation vor dem Bundestag gerade
wurde wegen Gesetzesänderung wieder viel
über Abtreibung in Deutschland
diskutiert was würde auf deinem
demonstrationsschild stehen
irgendwie abtreiben müssen fester
Bestandteil des gynäkologiestudium sein
was sie ja nicht sind es muss
sichergestellt sein dass es eine gute
medizinische Versorgung gibt und dass
ich
Medizinstudenten das anhand von Papaya
selber beibringen man nimmt die Frucht
man nimmt die Frau ja und irgendwie
macht Ausschabung lernt man halt mit
einem Skalpell an der Papaya und das ist
halt sorry in dem Land wie Deutschland
finde ich das eine Katastrophe also ich
möchte Eingriffe sicher aber es wird
diese Eingriffe weiterhin geben ich
möchte dass Sie natürlich in einer Form
gemacht werden die unter medizinisch
sicheren Umständen sind mal gemacht
werden werden sie das wissen wir die
Mutter meines Großvaters ist halt an
einer illegalen Abtreibung gestorben das
hat ihn für sein Leben geprägt und das
hat auch mich einfach nachhaltig geprägt
okay bei vielen Dank kommt zurück zu mir
auf die Couch
da gab es Momente wo ich das Gefühl
hatte me Tools noch relativ ruhig
geblieben Cornelia bei dir gab es
Grimassen wo ganz klar wurde also du
hast zum Teil den Kopf massiv
geschüttelt wo war für dich ein Punkt wo
du sagst da wollte ich am liebsten
umdrehen und was erwidern bei der
medizinischen Ausbildung weil das das
finde ich das geht gar nicht wenn wir
wollen dass Frauen eine ordentliche
Gesundheitsversorgung bekommen dann
müssen wir erstmal die Bereiche fördern
und stärken in denen wirklichen Manko
ist wo wir wirklich ein Problem haben
dass die Geburtshilfe das ist nicht die
Abtreibung dass das erste ganz kurz
sollen nicht lernen wie man Abtreibung
durchführt nein wozu meine Meinung ist
das ist Abtreibung gibt und irgendwie
wenn es Abtreibung gibt dann ist es
unsere Verpflichtung sie gut so
Unterrichtende Medizinstudium dafür zu
sorgen dass wir sie menschenwürdiger
Form machen in welchem Szenario werden
Abtreibung okay eine Abtreibung ist in
keinem Szenario für mich okay erstmal
prinzipiell mein Punkt ist dass ich sage
es muss erstmal alles getan werden um
der Frau ein Leben mit dem Kind zu
ermöglichen und um den Frau sagt ich
will das auf keinen Fall ja da würde ich
tatsächlich das Leben und die
Entscheidung was eigene Leben höher
setzen weil gezwungen werden eine
Schwangerschaft ausgetragen finde ich
eine also ein Eingriff in die
Selbstbestimmung und es ist also eine
Schwangerschaft ist ein so großer
Eingriff in das eigene Leben in den
eigenen Körper und das kann ich nur
freiwillig machen wir können den Wert
eines Menschen und die Frage ob er
weiterleben darf oder nicht nicht
abhängig machen davon wie abhängig und
schutzbedürftig dieser Mensch ist klar
zwingen sich um ein Baby zu kümmern
sondern gleich zu sagen
vielleicht den Punkt eben noch zu Ende
bringen weil auch diese die Frage wie
wir darüber reden ganz entscheidend ist
also ähm ich muss nicht unbedingt sagen
das ist ein Kind ein Kind ist immer nur
eine altersbeschreibung ganz wichtiger
Punkt wo man vielleicht mal gucken kann
was heißt denn überhaupt Mensch sein
worüber sprechen wir solange der Mensch
noch nicht geboren ist das Wesen noch
nicht geboren ist
das sind die Wochen der Schwangerschaft
und das muss ich direkt dazu sagen es
ist nicht immer Maßstab dargestellt hier
vier Wochen ist ungefähr so groß
das ist leben ja natürlich
also die Welt ist belebt und also
deshalb irgendwie natürlich wird
irgendwie dieses Samenkörnchen da auch
belebt sein die Frage ist ist es ein
Mensch und das das weiß ich nicht das
kann ich wirklich nicht sagen aber die
Naturwissenschaft also da gibt es
genau sagen dass ich kann dir sagen das
ist erstens mal es gehört zu Spezies
Menschen ist keine anderen Spezies der
wird kein Pony drauf zweitens es wird
kontinuierlich wachsen und zwar als
Mensch drittens es ist ein komplettes
Individuum mit einer eigenen DNA die
sonst kein anderer Mensch hat und es hat
viertens das Potenzial zu jemandem wie
mir tut zu werden hallo
[Gelächter]
Eizelle hat ebenfalls irgendwie all das
was du beschreibst und trotzdem eine
Eizelle die nicht befruchtet ist hat das
nicht acht Wochen ja das wäre jetzt so
groß wie eine Blaubeere ist das jetzt
ein Moment wo du sagst das ist dann mehr
Mensch als das kleine kümmelkorn ich
möchte überhaupt nicht entscheiden wann
wird es Menschen nur noch mal zum
Verständnis das hier ist für Dich
genauso ein Mensch wie dieses kleine
Körnchen Kümmel wie Methode die da sitzt
ja darf ich dann fragen wenn ich jetzt
eine Abtreibung in dem Moment mache wie
mir tut das gemacht hat einige Wochen
nach der Befruchtung
wer das dann für dich dasselbe dass man
sagt das Kind ist jetzt drei Jahre alt
und ich komme damit nicht klar ich will
es irgendwie nicht ich kriege es nicht
hin oder es ist vielleicht auch aus
einer Vergewaltigung entstanden ich gehe
zum Arzt und sage ich will das Kind
abgeben und dann wird das Kind
umgebracht das ist von den Reihen von
den Fakten her ist es das gleiche ich
würde eindeutig sagen eine Abtreibung
ist nicht die Tötung eines Menschen ich
würde sagen das ist noch kein Mensch und
in jedem Fall nehme ich diesen Menschen
die Zukunft egal egal wie alt ist das
ist immer das was passiert und ähm also
ich weiß dass wir uns das als
Gesellschaft leicht machen weil es
hinter verschlossenen Türen passiert und
weil wir diesen Menschen nicht sehen
deswegen zusammengefasst drei Jahre
altes Kind umzubringen wäre genauso wie
ein ein Zellhaufen abzutreiben der eine
Woche alt ist ja von den Fakten
die eine sagt Abtreibung müssen okay
sein mein Körper meine Entscheidung die
andere sagt achtung da wird ein Leben
getötet das geht nicht lasst uns da
jetzt noch mal rein hätten wir noch mal
Platz zu machen
ungewollt schwanger mit 15 das passiert
und gar nicht so selten und es wirkt
wahrscheinlich unglaublich viele Fragen
auf ich will jetzt sehen was die beiden
einer 15-Jährigen in dieser Situation
raten wir stellen uns jetzt vor das wäre
das Beratungsgespräch und ich habe hier
mir folgendes Szenario überlegt wovon
ich glaube das ist so stattfindet wenn
nicht korrigiert mich in die 15-Jährige
in dem Fall jetzt metoo kommt in diese
Situation rein und würde dann so etwas
sagen wie ich bin so unsicher was soll
ich tun ich bin schwanger ja ich bin
aber nicht mal in der festen Beziehung
und dann habe ich auch noch irgendwie
die Ausbildungsstelle ab Herbst und da
könnte ich dann auch nicht hier mit dem
Kind und Mama weiß Bescheid und die sagt
ich soll's gut überlegen weil ich soll
mir mein Leben nicht verpfuschen aber
irgendwie ist da ja auch ein Lebewesen
Papa habe ich das noch gar nicht erzählt
weil der würde komplett ausrasten wegen
der Schwangerschaft und ich weiß
wirklich nicht was ich tun soll wie du
das ist jetzt deine Ausgangslage stell
dir vor das ist dein letzter Satz ich
weiß wirklich nicht was ich tun soll und
dann bereit Cornelia dich ich hätte gern
die Möglichkeit trotzdem meine
Ausbildung zu machen ich hätte gerne die
Möglichkeit wenn ich das Kind bekomme
trotzdem ein Leben zu leben in dem ich
mich entwickeln kann nehmen wir mal an
diese Möglichkeiten würden dir alle
eingeräumt also jemand würde sagen wir
kümmern uns um dein Kind nehmen du
jemand würde dir versprechen dass du
deine Ausbildung zu Ende machen kannst
jemand würde dir sagen dein Leben wird
anders aber es wird nicht unbedingt
schlechter wie würde sich denn dein
Unsicherheitsgefühl verändern dann hätte
ich eine echte Wahl also eine echte
und wäre es dann vielleicht möglich dass
du sagst dann könnte ich mich auch für
das Kind entscheiden
vielleicht also wenn wenn ich eine
15-jährige wäre die grundsätzlich ein
Kind möchte vielleicht ich habe hier
gerade das Gefühl dass imitor richtig
was passiert weil sie sich genau
erinnert weil sie das erlebt hat wie das
war mit 15 abzutreiben und gleichzeitig
bleibt Cornelia komplett in ihrer Rolle
dieser Beraterin drin weil das für sie
die Realität ist ich hätte gerne ein
Dorf dass ich mit um das Kind kümmert
dass ich hätte gerne ja genau gerne
andere Menschen die sich genauso
verantwortlich für das Kind fühlen gibt
es jemanden wenn du mal nachdenkst in
deinem Freundeskreis mit dem du schon
mal darüber gesprochen hast der
vielleicht so eine Hilfe sein könnte
eine Freundin oder Mitschülerin eine
Tante eine Oma irgendjemanden von dem du
denkst ach vielleicht könnte ich den mal
fragen oder ansprechen was Cornelia hier
macht ist ja sie sagt ganz gleich ich
will keinem irgendwie rein reden aber
sie nutzt framing sie setzt alles in
einen Rahmen wie wir das in der
Psychologie nennen und der ist bei ihr
nur rosaro ich bin mir absolut sicher
dass jemand einmal sich für eine Stunde
und das Kind kümmern würde das hilft mir
nicht weiter das Kind wird sterben wenn
ich mich nicht kümmer also habe ich das
Kind 24 Stunden am Tag sieben Tage die
Woche wir haben ja eine 15-jährige die
vor wie viel Jahren dann in Mitte 80er
Jahren in Mitte der 80er Jahren da saß
und dachte
ich schaffe es nicht ich packe es nicht
wenn so jemand zu dir ins
Beratungsgespräch kommt hier sitzt sie
jetzt willst du die dann überzeugen das
Kind zu kriegen
das will ich immer also mir geht es
immer darum zu versuchen zu sagen das
ist es immer die schönere Entscheidung
mit diesem Kind leben zu können und mein
Anliegen das Anliegen meiner
Organisation ist wirklich alles dafür zu
tun dass das der Frau das auch gelingt
dieses Jahr zum Kind zu sagen was ich
schwierig finde ich kenne das in
Beratungsgesprächen das gesagt wird hier
sitzen ja drei Menschen im Raum das
finde ich schwierig weil wenn ich mich
sowieso dazu entscheide abzutreiben und
an Braas Geschichte brauche und dann
noch mit dem Gefühl rausgehen ist doch
noch eine Mörderin hurra also ne das
braucht das hilft mir ja nicht weiter
lasst uns einmal bitte die Positionen
tauschen und jetzt machen wir folgendes
und Cornelia ich wette das wird auch
sehr schwierig für dich stell dir bitte
vor du wärst jetzt eine 15-jährige die
abtreiben möchte was gibst du dieser
junge Frau mit bitte
also ich würde dir wirklich raten wenn
es irgendwie möglich ist geht zu
Kristina Hänel weil das auf gar keinen
Fall ich weiß dass du das nicht machen
würdest aber geh zu Frau Hänel die macht
das besonders nett mit den Abtreibungen
da musste ich lachen weil ich gedacht
habe unter Beratung verstehe ich jetzt
was anderes wenn du einen magst mal kurz
beschreiben
ist Ärztin die die sich ganz stark in
Deutschland dafür eingesetzt hat das
Ärztin informieren konnten in dass sie
Abtreibung von in welcher Form sie das
machen und so weiter genau und was hat
sie was macht sie noch was sie macht was
sie für mich besonders macht ist sie
redet mit den Menschen die zu ihr kommen
sie sagt den es gibt die Möglichkeit ich
würde dir eher raten es so zu machen das
ist die abtram die für dich besser
laufen kann solche Sachen also dass sie
dass sie sagt das ist etwas das sollst
du besser bei mir in der Klinik machen
die redet während der Abtragung mit den
mit den Menschen also in meine
Abtreibung waren immer die Hölle weil
ich absolut entmündigt war daran ich
habe gerade gedacht eine Abtreibung wird
nicht dadurch besser dass sie mir
blumigen Worten irgendwie als schönes
Erlebnis verkauft werden ich glaube
tatsächlich nicht dass ich dir Versuche
im blumigen Worten zu verkaufen sondern
dass ich sage ich möchte eine
menschenwürdige Abtreibung haben als
wird sie sowieso geben wird sie dadurch
besser dass die Person die abtreibt
schlecht behandelt wird
im Beratungsraum ihr habt den wieder zur
Couch gemacht was ich gut finde ich will
jetzt tiefer in eure Lebensgeschichte
dran zu verstehen warum ihr da steht mit
euren Punkten wo ihr steht und ihr habt
ja beide auch Erlebnisse mitgebracht die
glaube ich eine Rolle spielen lass uns
einmal noch mal auf die Couch zurück
[Musik]
ihr beiden das keine echte Therapie und
die läuft heute in vielen Fällen ja auch
ganz anders ab trotzdem finde ich immer
spannend mal ein Setup zu schaffen
und einfach mal ganz frei erzählen kann
warum er oder sie da steht wo sie heute
steht und die andere Person versucht mal
bei aller Konfrontation wertschätzend
diese Situation zu verstehen du wirst
jetzt zur Therapeutin
mich interessiert irgendwie in welchen
Lebenssituationen wir haben ja jetzt
über die erste Abtreibung gesprochen in
welchen Lebenssituationen kam es zu den
beiden anderen Abtreibungen
das war relativ kurz nach der Geburt
also knappes Jahr nach der Geburt meines
Sohnes da habe ich meinen jetzigen Mann
kennengelernt und also ich kenne ich
kann dir vor dem zusammengekommen und da
hat einfach so wie ich vorher absolut
sicher verhütet habe nicht mehr
funktioniert was hast du denn dafür
Gespräche geführt mit deinem Mann mein
Sohn war halt noch sehr sehr klein meine
Mutter lag im Sterben und es war also
ich war halt Freiberuflerin und ähm was
nicht also weil in Deutschland damals
die Vorstellung war mit Kind wollen wir
nicht unterstützen damit du möglich zu
Hause bleiben kannst als freiberuflich
Journalistin wenn du ein paar Jahre zu
Hause bleibst bist du nicht mehr
freiberufliche Journalistin und ich war
absolut am Rande meiner Ressourcen wie
findest du das ist Frauen gibt die sagen
das wollen wir euch verbieten verbieten
ist der Punkt an dem bei mir auch alles
zugeht weil mir das wirklich
Ängste macht
wahrscheinlich hätte ich es trotzdem
gemacht ich habe damals im Internet
recherchiert welche Alternativen es gibt
ich weiß von Freundinnen von mir die die
mit irgendwie baumwalsamen abgetrieben
haben und allem möglichen also es ist
wirklich ich habe panisch nach
Möglichkeiten gesucht was ist was ist
also als 15-Jähriger ne ich habe in
meinem Leben ganz lange irgendwie habe
mich das verzweifelt gemacht und wird
man was auch immer ich bin ja im Moment
dadurch gegangen also ich habe ja
irgendwie langes irgendwie eine lange
Auseinandersetzung mit dem Thema anderen
Ende dass ich halt einfach nur weiß es
ist nicht es ist nicht erfolgreich also
irgendwie ist wird es ist wird nicht
weniger Abtragung gegen dadurch es wird
nur mehr Tote geben wollen wir einmal
tauschen bitte du wirst jetzt die Rolle
der Therapeut sich dass wir in
Anführungsstrichen einnehmen ich bin
gespannt warum du da stehst wo du stehst
ja genau gespannt Liebe Cornelia
ich bin ja sehr sehr beeindruckt davon
wie viel Energie du auch da reinsteigst
anderen Menschen zu helfen und das ist
ja etwas das macht man nicht weil man
denkt dass es richtiger falsch sondern
da muss es ja etwas geben was sich
antreibt und diese Energie da rein zu
stecken was ist das ich mag Babys ich
freue mich total wenn ich jemanden sehe
deren Kinderwagen durch die Gegend
schiebt ich freue mich wenn ich eine
Schwangere sehe mal Kinder auch gerne
und ich mache es trotzdem nicht da
steckt ja noch mehr dahinter dass du so
viel Energie da reinsteckst auch
wirklich in andere Menschen reinschickst
ja das steckt die Überzeugung hinter
dass wir unsere Welt nicht besser machen
wenn wir eine einen ganzen Teil unserer
Menschheit die Menschenrechte von
vornherein komplett Kappen Cornelia
bleibt Therapeutin eigentlich soll sie
doch jetzt auf der Couch mal ihre
Lebensgeschichte erzählen ich habe das
Gefühl sie ist immer noch damit
beschäftigt wie tu ihre Meinungs
präsentieren ich vermisse so ein
bisschen die Lockerheit auch im Umgang
mit mit Kindern das einzige was ein Kind
wirklich braucht um zu gedeihen ist
Liebe seiner Eltern alles andere ist
nicht so wichtig das ganze Geld ist
nicht so wichtig die Lebensumstände die
Wohnung das ist alles zweitrangig ein
Kind braucht erstmal liebe ja sehe ich
aber dass das ist ja trotzdem du hast
dich entschieden du möchtest
ungeborenes Leben schützen warum hast du
dich dafür entschieden und nicht dafür
weiß ich nicht irgendwie Seenotrettung
zu machen ja
gibt es ein ganz einfachen Grund
Seenotrettung macht machen sich
Organisation macht die Kirche die haben
ihre Schiffe das wird politisch
wahnsinnig unterstützt das weiß ich
mache machen weniger was ich total
spannend finde ist wenn du das sagst
dass du das Gefühl hast da setzen sich
so wenige in diesem Land für ein ich
habe ja genauso das Gefühl dass ich
nicht an der wegen mir die abgetrieben
aber überhaupt nicht aber dass ich eine
der wenigen wenn die öffentlich darüber
redet und wie viel wenig Themen kriege
ich so viel gegenwünsche ich denke WoW
und und deshalb irgendwie es ist ganz
spannende aus dem Gefühl heraus sprechen
wir sind darin marginalisiert also dass
du marginalisiert bist mit deinem
Eintreten für Abtreibung das halte ich
für ein Gerücht mit Verlaub wir reden ja
nicht darüber also es ist halt immer
etwas wir machen das wir reden nicht
drüber ja klar und das ja auch bisschen
klar wir reden auch nicht über wir reden
auch nicht darüber wenn wir ein Kind
missbraucht haben oder wenn wir laden
Diebstahl begangen haben
also
ist nicht ist nicht genau das gleiche
Ladendiebstahl und Abtreibung und
Abtreibung viel schlimmer ich nehme bei
einer Abtreibung einem Kind endgültig
ein für allemal alle Zukunft ja gut aber
das mache ich auch mit Verhütung also
mit Verhütung irgendwie nehme ich auch
allen potentiellen Kindern nein bei
einer Verhütung ist ja kein Kind da ist
ja quatsch seitdem du nimmst eine
Verhütungsmethode bei der auch eine
Abtreibung die Folge ist
das ist ein Moment wo ich gerne was mit
euch ausprobieren würde und auch
überhaupt nicht weiß ob das klappt umso
gespannter bin ich jetzt helfe mir mal
Platz Mann
es gibt beim Thema Abtreibung und der
Gesetzeslage in Deutschland natürlich
auch um Macht wer hat wie viel Macht
über wen wer hat welche Macht über den
Körper Wert welche Macht über das
Ungeborene ich möchte jetzt mit Euch
beiden eine Skulptur bauen wo wir genau
diese Machtverhältnisse einmal greifbar
machen kannst du eine Skulptur bauen die
könnte jetzt so aussehen das vielleicht
ein Schlag gegen dich kommt oder eine
Umarmung oder du sagst die steht ganz
weit weg von mir oder die sitzt auf dem
Boden während ich ganz oben mächtig bin
versuch mal in Bild in einem Bild zu
fassen wie du das wahrnimmst wenn jemand
dir als Schwangere gegenüber sagt wir
brauchen Deutschland Recht auf
Abtreibung ich ähm ich hätte dann fast
sogar lieber vielen Mann stehen als eine
Frau weil ich ja vorhin schon mal gesagt
haben ich glaube dass dass du hast
richtig Lust gehabt ja falls Du mir tun
habt brauchst natürlich
super danke schön weil ich denke das das
ist etwas was wir noch viel zu wenig mit
in diese Gleichung reingenommen haben da
ist ein Vater der für dieses Kind hier
auch Verantwortung zu übernehmen hat wie
hättest Du mich gerne positioniert nimm
meine armen in meinem Kopf Beine ich
hätte dann glaube ich ähm wenn ich ganz
brutal wäre hätte ich gesagt ich nehme
das Bein und verpasse dir so brutal wie
das möchtest Schuhgröße 48 tritt jetzt
den schwangeren Bauch kaputt du sagst
Bescheid wenn ich und ich würde dann
sagen ja und jetzt wollen wir das Foto
komm ruhig an
richtig Achtung
das rutscht da jetzt irgendwo raus
es muss noch mal kurz erklären der Bauch
der kaputt getreten wird vom Vater wieso
weil ich weil weil ich das erlebe auch
in unserer Beratung dass so viel Druck
ausgeübt wird auf die Frauen und das so
oft gesagt wird entweder du treibst ab
oder ich bin weg und Frauen sind in
dieser Situation sowohl ne Rabel auch
weil auch einfach aufgrund der
hormonellen Umstellung und dass wir sie
brauchen ist ein Partner der sagt super
wir sind schwanger das ist ja toll ja
das Leon mit drin war also das ist
irgendwie natürlich auch eine weitere
Partei gibt die an einer Schwangerschaft
beteiligt ist fand ich super dass darauf
treten das ist ihr Gefühl auch ein
gewisser Form das ist mir unter die Haut
gegangen ist Rollentausch jetzt du
[Musik]
du bist jetzt die Bildhauerin hier sind
deine Utensilien eigentlich hätte ich
das Gefühl dass du mir den hinten
anschnallst mach mal bitte
gleich und ich würde es mir so den Kopf
da vorne drücken weil ich muss das
machen ich habe nicht die Wahl muss mich
aber trotzdem kümmern weil es ist ja
trotzdem dann leben was auf der Welt ist
das heißt es ist ja nicht die Schuld des
Lebens
beschreib mal von hinten kommt jemand
schnall dir den Bauch um genau und ich
habe keinen Einfluss darauf
das ist aber das ist natürlich das jetzt
ihr Gefühlskultur darf Aufstehen so
erstmal wenn Abtreibung in Deutschland
verboten wäre wäre das das Gefühl was
ich dazu hätte das ist nicht mein
Frauenbild das ist auch nicht das was
ich erreichen möchte dass das eine das
zweite ist ich fand extrem dass sie
wollte dass ich auch den Kopf noch mal
runter beuge bei meinen Gefühl eben ein
anderes ist eine Frau wird nicht
schwächer dadurch dass sie ein Kind zur
Welt bringt sondern stärker wir leben ja
trotzdem in einer Welt in dem halt nur
die Menschen nicht schwanger werden
können was ja nur ein Teil der
Bevölkerung ist alle Folgen davon tragen
müssten das heißt irgendwie ich müsste
dann das Kind austragen ich müsste mich
darum kümmern dass dieses Kind am Leben
bleibt ich müsste so ich muss dieses
Kind ernähren und alles nö das musst du
für neun Monate du musst aber wenn das
Baby auf der Welt ist dann muss liegen
lassen nein das kannst du das musst du
nicht es gibt auch die Möglichkeit Herze
gehen und zu sagen wo ist denn jetzt der
Vater
jetzt lass doch einfach mal also das
gibt es ja aber ich kann kein Vater in
diesem zwingen zu kümmern das ist nicht
möglich nein du hast doch du kannst du
kannst doch hergehen und sagen du hast
es Sorgerecht du bist Vater ich bin raus
nicht Sorgepflicht das ist ein
Unterschied Sorgerecht ist nur ein Recht
das ist dass man aber dass man
entscheiden kann was medizinische aber
sorge Pflicht ist aber ich kann keine
Lebenszeit hergehen und sagen das Kind
ich ich stelle meinen Körper für 9
Monate zur Verfügung von diesen 9
Monaten sind vielleicht richtig
beschwerlich wir haben das ja beide auch
erlebt ähm die letzten drei Monate und
vorher kannst du ja alles machen du bist
ja verhältnismäßig frei du verzichtest
mal ein bisschen auf Alkohol vielleicht
oder Zigaretten oder was auch immer also
wo ich wirklich Schwierigkeiten hatte
ach das ist ja nur eine Schwangerschaft
in den letzten drei Monaten anstrengend
da muss man halt mal durch nachdem das
Adoption freigegeben wo ich denke nee
also das das kann ich gar nicht teilen
zum Schluss noch einmal die bitte euch
gegenüber zu kommen und jetzt gibt euch
die Hände beide
sogar über Kreuz das ist jetzt das ist
ja eine richtige verschwesterung okay
stellt euch vor ihr seid beste Freundin
ihr mögt euch richtig richtig gerne die
eine sagt trotzdem bitte bitte alles
gegen Abtreibung tun die andere sagt wir
brauchen das Recht darauf ist es mir so
wichtig und jetzt stellen wir uns vor du
hast abgetrieben das ist passiert
Cornelia ihr wollt befreundet werden was
gibst du deiner Freundin mit mir zu was
sagst du hier vielleicht wo du weißt sie
war so sehr dagegen damit ihr zusammen
als Freundin weiterleben könnt das tut
mir total leid dass du diese
Entscheidung getroffen hast das schmerzt
mich richtig aber du bist trotzdem meine
Freundin und ich bin immer für dich da
es bewegt mich es bewegt mich wirklich
dass es dich Schmerz total ich finde ich
finde es ja auch okay ich meine die
meisten meiner Freundin Teilen nicht
alle meine Haltung und dann bestimmten
Punkten auch ein paar sehr grundlegende
nicht ich kann ich kann damit leben dass
ist echt anders siehst vielleicht in der
freundschaftlichen Umarmung am Ende
angekommen ich kann mir vorstellen dass
viele die hier zu gucken diese Umarmung
nicht geteilt hätten und da sehr viel
krassere Position noch mal gegengehalten
hätten aber ihr beide seid
zusammengekommen am Ende
ich hoffe sehr dass mein Standpunkt klar
geworden ist ich habe tatsächlich jetzt
nicht argumentiert im Blick auf die
Leute die Sendung angucken sonst ging
mir wirklich darum mit Cornelia zu reden
und uns zu ihr durchzudringen meine
schönste Erkenntnis heute war das ähm da
jemand ist tatsächlich auf der
sogenannten anderen Seite der mit meiner
Position sehr wertschätzend umgegangen
ist und der gesagt hat du darfst diese
Position vertreten das Thema ist so
krass emotional es geht ja einerseits um
die Entscheidung der Frauen und
andererseits auch um die Frage das ist
ein Ungeborenes Wesen dass ich nicht
schützen kann wie stehst du zur
Abtreibung jetzt in die Kommentare
[Musik]